can you educate me on the difference
between bass bass and bass okay well one
is a fish at least I pronounced it
correctly that's
good uh it's all about the can you
pronounce my my name tall
wow most people say t t or tall you said
tall who says tall like so many people
in the South maybe tall I don't know but
the fact that you my you get extra point
oh I can't I didn't know this was a game
am I winning y I like
winning how do you play the bass uh
what's the difference between finger
style and slap slap is like this finger
style is like this you ever ever played
bass with a pick yeah sometimes I'm not
accusing you of anything no accusation
taken I don't know if these are
sensitive topics like if that would be
pretty hilarious if how sensitive about
bass techniques but like not about like
love it just looks so cool to like slap
it but and I don't understand what
that's about like that thumb thing that
yeah I slap less um a lot less almost
never actually um it has a very
distinctive sound and does a very
distinctive thing to a song that um is
not something I hear needed very often
in music today yeah um but in certain
Styles like Funk it sounds awesome and
it makes sense it was something that was
a bit overused at one
point um for instance like my mentor
Anthony Jackson he refused to slap like
he actually said if you want me to slap
I'll leave this gig MH so I'm not like
that see that's why I said sensitive see
I was like reading into it cuz he was
he's sensitive about I was feeling the
spiritual energy of the sensitivity of
Anthony Jackson and then I mean I'm
playing Electric Bas so generally
speaking you don't particularly want to
hear electric bass on Straight Ahead
Jazz anyway you want to hear an upright
Bass But if I was to play jazz on
electric base I might even kind of th
like palm palm mute you know like
instead of going like I might
go to very yeah anything to kind of make
the the notes um shorter and less
resonant and like going to fade away
quick cuz the upright does that
naturally and I have like a different
base like a hollow body Harmony that
sounds closer to an upright that I'll
use um in in certain like on my song
Under the Sun that I put out that was on
a Harmony base and it has like kind of
an upright acoustic kind of tone to it
but with more
sustain and uh is jazz fusion the the
style where you have like an electric
base can you add your came with again
you can you can have both you can have
both on you can have either on anything
there's no like real rules now I've
heard you say something interesting
which is uh well a lot of things you say
is interesting but just one thing just
one that and it's what time you're
leaving what time was that again three
minutes that it's maybe easier sometimes
to define a musical genre by the don'ts
than the than the dos
the don'ts than the
Dos uh what are the don'ts of jazz and
rock what are the don'ts of J Fusion
what are the don'ts in any domain of
Life what are the don'ts the don'ts is
just to to please leave your fear at the
door mhm and your does is to be open to
anything and open your ears like respond
to what's happening
now I think that quote you're talking
about about might have been more about
an an individual musician's unique sound
because everyone has their sound if
they've developed their voice and
they've listened to their own aesthetic
preferences of which everyone is
slightly different everyone has slightly
different likes and dislikes um then
you'll have a unique sound on your
instrument and your unique sound is
defined more by the choices you make
rather than I mean it's it's equally as
defined by the choices you make and the
choices you don't make I mean it's it's
the it's the flip side of the same coin
really yeah there's certain musicians
you can just tell it's them just you
hear a few notes and you're like okay
it's them tone sometimes it's tone
sometimes it's the way they put they
play Rhythm yeah it might that quote
you're talking about might have even had
to do with someone's like real
limitations on an instrument that then
that would define their sound as the
things that they can't like actually
can't do versus like what you're
choosing to do versus not choosing to do
which is that like flip side of the same
coin thing how many fingers you play
with it seems like a lot of the greatest
musicians aren't
technically like
perfect the the imperfections is the
thing that makes them unique and where a
lot of the creativity comes from I mean
Hendrick's Hendrick said a lot of those
things the way he put like a thumb over
the top well his hands were huge there
was no other place for the thumb to to
go and it was great that he could reach
you know the the E string and that was
an
advantage and he was a lefty playing a
right and a guitar yeah flipped I guess
yeah that's weird that probably doesn't
have much of an effect maybe a spiritual
one I don't know well actually flipping
a guitar is is is different it does you
know bring out something different in
you cuz I've done it like flipped in
it's like oh wow yeah really it's really
different I remember talking to about
like osteopath about like you know
because there's so much weight on this
shoulder while I'm playing all the time
and and they were saying like well just
after shows just literally just turn it
upside down do the exact same thing in
the opposite way it'll like even out
your body and I was like it's good
advice have you actually tried it mhm
okay all right I'll write that
down uh all right well do you know a guy
named Davey 504 I've heard of him I've
recently learned of him he's a YouTuber
and a bass player he's amazing he
combines memes and also just these
brilliant bass compositions and says
slap like a lot he's big into slapping
that's that's how that's he's the one
that kind of made me realize this is a
thing okay and he also said that you're
one of the best if not the best basist
in the world there was a bunch of his
fans that wrote in and he analyzed the
Jeff Beck thing that we watched at
Crossroads is one of of the greatest
solos ever Bas solos ever so shout out
to him what does that make you feel like
you're the greatest of all time
chocolate cookies chocolate is that your
favorite I like macadamia nut like if I
if you really want to get into it with
like white chocolate yeah that's a rare
one for people to say is the favorite
chocolate chip is just like easy you can
kind of get them anywhere yeah last
thing you want to be is easy in this
world you know want it be
easy
that